SPEAKER: Welcome to
"Google Cloud Drawing
Board," where we doodle
our way through the cloud.
Today's topic--
what is BigQuery?
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
enterprise data warehouse
designed to help you
ingest, store, analyze,
and visualize big
data with ease.
Organizations rely
on data warehouses
to aggregate data from
disparate sources,
process it, and make it readily
available for data analysis
that supports their
strategic decision-making.
You can ingest data into
BigQuery either through batch
uploading or streaming
data directly
to deliver real-time insights.
As a fully-managed
data warehouse,
Google takes care of
the infrastructure
so you can focus on analyzing
your data up to petabyte scale.
BigQuery supports the same
Structured Query Language,
or SQL, for analyzing
your data, which
you may be familiar
with if you've
worked with ANSI-compliant
relational databases
in the past.
If you're looking to create
machine learning models
using your enterprise data,
you can do so with BigQuery ML.
With only a few
lines of SQL, you
can train and execute
models on your BigQuery data
without needing
to move it around.
When it comes time to
visualize your data,
BigQuery integrates
with Looker, as well as
several other business
intelligence tools
across our partner ecosystem.
Now, how do you use BigQuery?
Luckily, it's
straightforward to get up
and running with BigQuery.
After creating a GCP
project, you can immediately
start querying public data
sets, which Google Cloud hosts
and makes available
to all BigQuery users,
or you can load your own data
into BigQuery to analyze.
Interacting with BigQuery to
load data, run queries, or even
create ML models can be done
in three different ways.
First is by using the UI
and the Cloud Console.
Second is by using the
BigQuery command line tool.
And third is by making
calls to the BigQuery API,
using client libraries
available in several languages.
BigQuery is integrated with
Google Cloud's Identity
and Access Management
Service so you can securely
share your data and
analytical insights
across the organization.
What does it cost
to use BigQuery?
With BigQuery, you pay
for storing and querying
data and streaming inserts.
Loading and exporting
data are free of charge.
Storage costs are based on
the amount of data stored
and have two rates based on
how often the data is changing.
Query costs can be
either on demand,
meaning you are charged per
query by the amount of data
processed, or flat rate for
customers who want to purchase
dedicated resources.
Want to learn more
about BigQuery?
Check out
cloud.google.com/bigquery.